des très bons pourquoi tu mens sur la
france a fait ce qui m'a fait on c'est
un fléau on s'est appelé au téléphone
nyamoya il ya trois semaines je lui ai
dit à quel point il était devenu beau
gosse il avait fait la coupe paul pogba
il a en costume 16 pièces et demie il
est bien que vous savez ce qu'on a dit
il m'a dit cette phrase qui m'a tuer il
m'a dit façon toi madic beau gosse ça
tirait pas s'agace tomber tu croyais que
j'allais dire ouais t'as raison ça lui
plaît même si j'ai fait un coup j'ai
fait rendez vous en terre inconnue et
c'est oui ils m'ont emmené les [ __ ]
au les scènes en lozère dans les
cévennes dans les cévennes mais saku
sais où je suis né ouais dans le gard
j'ai fait rendez vous en terre inconnue
à 15 minutes de chez moi
[Rires]
merci merci m les gars vous êtes venu en
dernier
merci quand même du raï khaled et ça
fait après mon oreillette frère il
t'avait thaddée miel pops dont on aurait
eu l'extrême on attend avant l'extrait
d'accord ce matin je ne regarde jamais
ses news
je te jure par hasard j'allume la télé
je tombe sur ses news il ya jean marc
morandini qui cartonne et jean marc
morandini je regarde y'a frédéric lopez
qui parle de l'émission de ce soir et il
lui fait un quiz il lui dit vous
préférez ce présentateur nice arrive à
toi vous référez yann barthès vous
préférez cyril hanouna way et il dit ben
je préfère yann barthès dans ma tête je
me dis arrête toi là
[Applaudissements]
c'est le matin je suis en sipec des miel
pops je regarde ça je me tiendrai toi
lie à l'émission ce soir
et là jean marc morandini est mourant
digne et google alert tout ça pourquoi
on préférait yann barthès dans ma tête
je me dis répond parce que parce que ne
va pas plus loin et il dit parce que ça
vole plus haut ouais je me suis dit
rajoute un truc des oiseaux les amis les
oiseaux nés un poteau en irène du temps
où il est allé la tête
j'appelle franck way jeudi franck fait
sûrs que si franck je parie que ce soir
cyril il parle pas de terrain connu est
ce que parce que près de lopez il a dit
qu'il préférait yann barthès franc qui
me dit mais jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie cyril ils sont fous il
a d'autres choses à faire
j'ai le message que tu m'as envoyé à
temps je vais te retrouver le message
c'est vrai pas à pas bon j'avais lu que
j'appelle franck à 13h15
13h39 message de cyril hanouna guerrero
je ne fais aucune promo ce soir pour le
traduire pèse et battu le tour cet
abruti de frais de la baisse et ça ça ne
m'a pas plus abattu que je te dise la
vérité
ouais c'est que c'est un deuxième siège
pour toi parce que fred lopez il est
avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
on s'attend pas à montreuil presque et
avec lui on du plectre épanouissement
est avec nous ce soir est ce qu est ce
que ça va mon prennent enfin oui alors
évidemment cyril c'était une blague
c'est un coup monté et il avait compris
mais je rigole pas c'est un coup mais la
tête du vito corleone avoir fait des
frets je voulais te dire mais taxi ça
sort demain ou pas je suis dans le
truman show tabac tu prends des notes
j'aime pas trop la complicité que vous
avez tous les deux à quoi sert alors
gardé secrètement jaloux non mais sans
déconner je vois il va redescendre où
c'est que le pratique depuis plus
longtemps qu au ccif un gars assez
froides aux pyramides au csu balance des
boldak hamas à bord les chérit le film
se déroule en thaïlande à pattaya et on
va tous faire ensemble a déjà fait
jamais fait à l'étranger et gérer que
vous mangez des choses bizarres la lui
alors lui l'uimm en ce printemps mais
vous il ya un problème il ya plus déjà
tu connais pas un vide on ne juge pas
j'ai un problème depuis longtemps c'est
sam franchement de parler de ça à la
télé ça va
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malu malu que tu viens ici man à chaque
fois sa vie les passe et combat look
déjà c'est rachid